[Music]  better this little chunk of this planet  do you have a plan X [ __ ] with PTSD and  a team that's mental you wanna kill him  oh yeah  why did you just say so they thrive in a  hot grounder and [ __ ] you ups their  idea of tourism let's get some  [Music]  what is that the ultimate predator  [Music]  [Music]  tell me about the mission did you see  anything unusual like an enemy  we saw something  oh yeah Benjamin someone or something  tore them to pieces I think they're  attempting hybridization they're  upgrading on every planet they visit we  need to know if you pose a threat  we're assassins there's imposing the  threat kind of deployed  [Music]  [Music]